Leo has $4,522.08 in
his bank account.
He deposits another
$875.50 and then
withdraws $300 in cash.
How much is left
in his account?
So he's starting
with $4,522.08.
Let's write that down.
$4,522.08.
And then he deposits, or he
adds, another $875.50.
So he's going to add $875.50.
When you deposit into an
account, you're putting
something into the account, or
you're adding to the account.
So after he adds that $875.50,
what does he have?
We go back to the penny spot,
or we could view that as the
hundredths.
A penny is one hundredth
of a dollar.
Let me switch colors.
We have 8 plus 0 is 8.
0 plus 5 is 5.
We have the decimal
right there.
2 plus 5 is 7.
2 plus 7 is 9.
5 plus 8 is 13.
Put the 3 down here and regroup
the 1, or carry the 1.
1 plus 4 is 5.
So after the $875.50 deposit,
he has $5,397.58.
Then he withdraws $300 in cash,
or he takes out $300, so
we'll have to subtract that.
So then he withdraws $300 and
I just added some trailing
zeroes after the decimal.
$300 is the same thing as
$300.00 and zero cents.
And then we subtract.
8 minus 0 is 8.
5 minus 0 is 5.
We have our decimal
right there.
7 minus 0 is 7.
9 minus 0 is 9.
3 minus 3 is 0, and then 5
minus nothing here is 5.
So he's the left with, in
his account, $5,097.58.